Oh, was jetzt?
Was, was
letzter Stream?
Jetzt wieder? Was letzter
Stream, Chat? Ja, okay.
Nice. Excellent.
Excellent.
Very gut.
Aber Chat, ich habe ja noch
keinen Plan, warum es nicht geht.
Vielleicht seid ihr SixHead
und pusht du das
später. Ja, kann ich machen.
Ich würde es ja gerne pushen,
wenn es funktioniert.
Aber ich kann es auch so
pushen, aber ich habe echt...
Du hast geguckt, das ist Stream 0
genau richtig. Okay.
Einmal irgendwas falsch rum hier.
End Duration
Buffer Size
Pointer.
Äh.
Haben wir nicht.
Duration ist das
zweite.
Warte mal. Moment.
Das ist das zweite. Passt schon.
Vielleicht liegt es echt an dem Video.
Vielleicht liegt das...
Ich meine, es könnte ja echt
an dem Video liegen.
Ich bin gerade etwas
planlos.
Vielleicht geht es auch irgendwann einfach so random.
Die Bufferlänge ist in
Bytes.
Also Anzahl Bytes.
Okay, vielleicht stirbt mit dem Video
irgendwas nicht.
Ich meine, wir haben es re-encoded.
Ich meine, allzu viel verkehrt
kann da nicht sein.
Oh, Baseline.
Okay.
Versuch mal mit Pixelformat.
Äh. Wieso? Ist es doch.
Ist es doch.
Did you try reducing video duration?
Maybe it's too large.
I calculate the video
the frame duration
with the values from FFmpeg.
And
16 milliseconds
seems right for
a 60 FPS
Video.
I think my video is in the wrong format.
Ist ja was.
Wir probieren mal was aus.
Also, wir machen jetzt erst nochmal eine Sache.
Wir nehmen das jetzt mal.
Ultra Fast Interments.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Wir speichern das mal in einem TS-File.
Einfach nur, dass kein MP...
Ich meine, MP4 ist an der Stelle
komplett weg.
Muss man ja auch mal sagen. Also MP4 ist komplett raus.
Das geht über
einen RTSP-Stream rein.
Das hat mit MP nichts zu tun.
Aber man weiß ja nicht.
Was hast du vor?
Videos streamen in meinen Browser
über WebRTC.
Und ich hab das schon mal mit Go gemacht.
Das funktioniert.
Aber jetzt gerade nicht.
Und ich glaube jetzt langsam liegt das echt an dem Videotrack.
Probieren wir jetzt nochmal aus.
Wann das...
Aber das mit dem Pixelformat ist nicht verkehrt.
Aber es ist ja eigentlich schon im...
Es ist ja eigentlich schon im richtigen Pixelformat.
Also, okay.
Ich glaube, es liegt da im Video.
Ich bräuchte einen Capture von einem meiner Webcams.
Aber das kann ich nicht machen, weil...
MonkaLeak.
Äh.
Okay.
Hä?
Ich hab doch nix geändert?
Also, wir haben jetzt...
Wir haben jetzt das Video
in einer anderen Datei gespeichert,
im Endeffekt.
Aber der Container ist doch
vollkommen egal an der Stelle.
Davon ist doch überhaupt nix mehr übrig.
Looted.
Auto. Play.
Okay.
Ich bin sehr...
Okay, wartet mal.
Jetzt, nachdem das Video läuft,
Output MP4 hauen wir jetzt mal rein.
Okay, das geht nicht.
Es macht keinen Sinn.
Der Container hat nichts mit dem zu tun,
was der da abspielt.
Der liest die einzelnen Frames raus.
Der weiß überhaupt nix mehr davon.
Achso.
Du musst es neu starten.
Guck mal, jetzt geht's auch wieder nicht mehr.
Doch, jetzt geht's wieder.
Okay, okay, okay, Leute.
Okay, der muss irgendwas anderes encoded haben.
Irgendwas hat der verkehrt encoded
in dem MP4-Video.
Wir müssen mal vergleichen,
was FFprobe da sagt.
Also, das...
Warum? Hä?
MP4 hat doch damit überhaupt
gar nichts mehr zu tun, Mann.
Okay, okay.
FFprobe.
Output.
Kann FFprobe mehrere Sachen?
Nee.
Okay, das ist alles wurscht.
Das hier ist das Stream.
Das ist das Interessante.
Input, Duration.
Bitrate.
Ja, die Bitrate ist ein bisschen anders.
Duration ist exakt gleich.
Ja.
Constraint.
Das ist das, worauf es ankommt.
Constraint, Baseline.
Okay, bla bla bla.
16 FPS.
Das ist doch genau...
Das ist doch genau das Gleiche da drin, Mann.
What?
Könnte eventuell am Filter liegen?
Wo? An welcher Stelle soll da ein Filter sein?
Ich meine, der Output ist doch genau das Gleiche.
Dieser ganze Mist.
Dieses ganze Metadaten-Zeug.
Das ist im Output überhaupt nicht mehr...
Also, davon sieht mein Browser nie was.
Add this to your command.
Äh, das haben wir ja auch.
Alles...
Alles Mist. Das hat damit doch gar nichts zu tun.
Okay, ich meine, das mache ich...
Ich meine, das ist gut, dass ich das hier...
Es ist gut zu wissen, dass es prinzipiell funktioniert.
Ich habe...
Ich meine, das muss...
Das muss mit kaputten China-Chinesen-Videos funktionieren, Mann.
Ja.
Wo soll ich das adden?
Hier.
Wo ist das F...
Ja, Moment.
Wo...
Wo hatten wir das jetzt hier gerade?
Ja.
Video-Codec.
Es ist sogar schon im richtigen Format.
Also, ich habe absolut keine Ahnung, warum das in...
Wie gesagt, es ist gut zu wissen, dass es funktioniert.
Es...
Aus meiner Sicht...
Leuchtet es nicht ein.
Weil der Videostream ist doch genau der gleiche.
Egal, ob MP4 oder...
Oder TS.
Das könnte auch...
Was weiß ich?
Das könnte auch MOV...
Könnte das sein oder so.
Spätestens an der Stelle wurde es der Videostream an den RTSP-Server geschickt, wird das MP4 doch schon weg.
Moment.
Beim Abspielen könnte sein, dass...
Leute, das liegt nicht an meinem Video-Format.
Das liegt an FFmpeg beim Abspielen.
FFmpeg beim Senden an den...
An den RTSP-Server macht er komisches Zeug.
Das wird es wahrscheinlich sein.
Ja, das ist genau wieder das Gleiche.
FFmpeg.
Gucken wir nochmal.
Ja, das von uns nicht.
Das von uns nicht.
Das liegt...
Das liegt aber nicht an mir.
Also, nicht an dem Videofile.
Ich bin mir relativ sicher, das liegt an dem Senden.
Zum RTSP-Server.
Output.
Da gucken wir mal, was der Unterschied ist jetzt dazwischen.
From Output MP4 hier.
Was ist der Unterschied?
Ich sehe da jetzt keinen drin.
Seht ihr einen?
Das da?
Zu...
Okay, hier sind irgendwelche Zusatzdinger gesetzt.
Hier sind irgendwelche Zusatzdinger gesetzt, ohne dass ich...
Also, der hintere Kram ist gleich.
Hier vorne ist noch irgendwelche...
Hier vorne ist noch irgendein Zusatzkrempel gesetzt.
Wo ich nicht weiß, was es heißen soll, ehrlich gesagt.
Es könnte aber auch sein, dass es das Gleiche heißt, nur hier nichts anzeigen kann.
Du hast Sprache geflamed, Beste.
Ja.
Ach, moin.
Moin.
Du hast Glück.
Vodafone hat gerade übelst rumgespackt.
Und Stream ist abgekackt.
Ja.
Ich bin jetzt aber auch gleich weg.
Aber zumindest, es funktioniert.
Es funktioniert.
Ich bin begeistert, Chat.
Ich weiß nicht...
Übrigens, Leute.
Mal so kurzer...
Kurzer...
Spoiler.
Kurzer Spoiler.
Der Paketo und ich, wir haben geplant...
Wir kennen uns so um mehrere Ecken.
Wir haben geplant, mal mit euch einen Kubernetes-Security-Stream zu machen.
Oder was in der Richtung.
Müssen wir mal gucken, wie wir das Ganze aufbauen.
Er ist nämlich...
Er ist nämlich konsultant für Kubernetes-Security.
Sowas gibt's auch, ja.
Bosschamp, ja.
Massive.
Also.
Ich zeige euch jetzt nochmal abschließend,
bevor ich abhaue, dass es funktioniert.
Oh.
Zack.
Hoffentlich...
Hoffentlich funktioniert es.
Hoffentlich geht's jetzt.
Pass auf, wahrscheinlich ist es jetzt kaputt und es funktioniert wieder nicht.
Doch.
Videospiel ab.
Also, Leute.
Ich hab kein...
Ich hab keinen Plan.
Ich hab wirklich keine Ahnung, warum das mit MP4 nicht geht, aber mit TS funktioniert.
Es leuchtet mir ums Verrecken nicht ein.
Das muss wahrscheinlich...
Also, ich glaube nicht, dass es an der Videodatei liegt.
Das muss daran liegen, dass FFmpeg das zum RTSP-Server schickt.
Dass das irgendwas Wirres macht.
Irgendwas ganz komisch konvertiert.
Und dass das deswegen nicht geht.
Keine Ahnung.
Aber prinzipiell funktioniert das WebRTC-Gestream.
Wann machst du den Stream zu Kubernetes?
Das haben wir uns noch nicht näher überlegt.
Müssen wir mal gucken.
Noch nicht...
Noch nicht geklärt.
Aber ich werde das schon im Vorfeld mal erzählen, dass keiner verpasst.
Dann habt ihr einen, der euch auch mal was erklären kann.
Der ein bisschen mehr Erfahrung hat als ich.
Was Kubernetes-Security-Sachen angeht.
Ihr kennt mich ja.
Ich schalte ja immer möglichst viel Security aus, dass es besser funktioniert.
Das ist...
Ihr wisst doch, wie das ist.
Wer es instant perfekt einrichtet und immer fehlerfrei, der muss nichts testen und er muss nichts dokumentieren.
Und nachdem er in dem Stream hier immer alles, wie man heute gesehen hat, prinzipiell alles komplett fehlerfrei funktioniert, ist es logisch.
Dann braucht man das nicht.
Zum Experimentieren Minikube.
Ob ich dir das empfehlen würde?
Ja, würde ich dir empfehlen.
Würde ich dir empfehlen.
Also ich persönlich mag Minikube.
Falls der Paketo noch da ist, wir können ihn fragen, was er empfehlen würde zum Experimentieren mit Kubernetes.
Also ich bin ja Minikube-Fan.
Manche schwören auf K3S.
Wahrscheinlich hängt es ein bisschen von ab, was man machen muss, beziehungsweise was man machen will.
Ich mag Minikube.
Einfach, weil man sagen kann, zack.
Minikube.
Minikube delete.
Alles wieder weg.
Minikube start.
Kubernetes lokal wieder da.
Kubectl und so.
Alles schon eingerichtet.
Das funktioniert.
Ubuntu oder Fedora?
Ehrlich gesagt, nix von beidem.
Also für was?
Desktop?
Auf dem Desktop würde ich es nicht verwenden.
Auf dem Server?
Ubuntu.
Guckt, zack.
уже viele Kluster am Start don't zucker.
Ja, lokales basteln Kubernetes am Start.
Und wenn man fertig ist, sagt man delete.
und es ist wieder fort so chat wenn mir irgendjemand erklären kann wenn irgendjemand
was gesehen hat was ich nicht gesehen habe ja was der unterschied ist da gibt es gibt es gratis ab
herr was der unterschied ist zwischen dem mp4 file und dem ts file ich habe gar keine ahnung
start und bitrate das ist es nicht das kann es nicht sein es ist exakt der gleiche videos
team ok also also die endung die endung ist weg spätestens wenn es als er an den rtsp sauber
geschickt wird also wir machen jetzt mal eine sache um festzustellen ob es irgendwie an dem
video files liegt und zwar wir kopieren den video stream wir kopieren den video stream aus dem einen
fall in block mp4
ok entdeckt auf video file was zweimal encoded wurde ja das ich glaube das nicht so die beste
idee so fertig also sagt ja blubb hoffentlich geht das jetzt wenn es nicht geht habe ich keine
ahnung aber ich wollte pendler es geht das okay dann legt das dann legt das nicht an dem mp4 was
er hoch lädt sondern
ich glaube ich muss doch so das ist das doch eigentlich sehr viel mehr für ein mp4
video ich weiss was das ist also ich bin da jetzt noch mal die erste gang mit dem mp4
video ich will dass ich gerade auf dem mp4 habe ich ein video und das ist ja zum beispiel
die frau gerne meine frau die fragte hat war was ist denn das ist ja jetzt schon vorales
ich glaube da ging das so und dann habe ich die frau auf das mp4 und ich habe sie mal
mit den den mps versichert und so und dann kommt das mal das ist ja so es ist glaube ich
dass es mal verlangt ich weiß nicht ob es so ist aber ich glaube es sieht irgendwie anders
fast hat aber davon sieht der browser doch gar nichts aber ich mache das ich kann das machen
ja das testen wir jetzt als letztes noch wenn du mir noch sagt wie man wie man options jemand
options setzt das weiß ich nämlich auch im kopf am besten will nicht club 2 punkt mp4
ffm pack das hier minus minus moff flex alles klar ob wir es nie wäre das die cringe wer das
nicht weiß danach muss den ordner wieder löschen ich habe unsinnigerweise gerade irgendwie 80 gig
videos oder so herumliegen wobei nie so groß ist das nicht ein paar minuten 8 mbit ist nicht
so groß kannst du sie schafft die frame größe anzeigen
du weißt du meinst die die dimension oder du meinst die größe in beides die größe in beides
haben wir schon anzeigen lassen ist irgendwo um 20 k rum oder so dass das kommt schon hin
ich kann das ich kann das machen also die dimension bin ich mir nicht sicher ich glaube
das kann man das hat man hier nicht ja ich glaube dazu muss man dass die code dass man das weiß wobei
muss man nicht keine ahnung wie man das wie man das auslesen kann
aber ich kann euch die ich kann euch die größer zeigen hier sei es
jetzt haben wir das mit dem fast start drin dann probieren wir das noch mal
club 2 bin ich mal gespannt und und es geht nicht das liegt irgendwie ein kohle der das
kugel um die 20 k haben wir ungefähr das ist nicht dass das kann auch nicht am container liegen aber
es ist egal leute wurscht egal weil prinzipiell geht's und das stream von der von china kamera
wird auch funktionieren moin luke bist genau richtig jetzt pen oder zumindest oder zumindest
gehe ich auf morgen früh ganz normal irgendwann zwischen 8 30 und 9 uhr 30 bin ich am start
kacke heute das wohnen von das wieder der stream abgekackt ist ne freund hier das hat man davor 205
oder sowas viewer das gleich gedroppt die ganzen lurker sind weg weil der stream abgekackt ist naja
also morgen zwischen 8 uhr 30 und 9 uhr 30 wieder am start naja sonntag ne stunde länger pennen sonst stehe ich 37 auf
wobei chat chat moment moment ich gehe morgen wieder eine runde rennen also eventuell eventuell auch ein paar minuten später aber 9 uhr 30 kommt ganz gut hin ich glaube nicht dass ich die große 10 kilometer runde mache morgen hab ich irgendwie keinen bock wetter wetter sieht auch nicht so geil aus ja ich weiß du bist sonntag morgens nieder es sind aber erstaunlich viele leute sonntag vormittags immer da hast du schon diablo 4 gespielt nö
habe ich großen bogen drum gemacht nachdem ich die ersten paar sachen gesehen habe obwohl das game ja glaube ich gar nicht so übel ist man spielt es mal dreimal durch auf den schwierigkeitsgraden und dann ist gut wobei das glaubt es hat gar keine so normalen schwierigkeitsgraden wie man das von den alten diablos kennt das habe ich ganz ehrlich normalerweise würde ich jetzt sagen das habe ich schon lange nicht mehr gemacht aber sowas habe ich eigentlich nie regelmäßig gemacht
ich bin schon immer er jemand gewesen der früh pennen geht und früh aufsteht wie gefällt der ballus geld 3 richtig gut weil das geld 3 ich habe es immer noch nicht durchgespielt weil der letzte weil der dritte akt etwas unfertig wirkt ja ich hatte dann auch irgendwann keinen bock mehr also merkt schon dass das polish in akt 1 und 2 ja eine ganze ecke höher ist als in akt 3
aber wenn ich mich entscheiden müsste so bei klassischen so rpgs die letzten jahre über rausgekommen sind da muss ich ehrlich sagen so die letzten zwei jahre da ist pathfinder wrath of the righteous rausgekommen und ballus geld 3 so von den größeren titeln muss ich ehrlich sagen es sind sehr unterschiedliche games ja aber für meinen geschmack gefällt mir das pathfinder game besser
das ist deutlich kampf
also fight heavier
ballus geld 3 ist halt deutlich mehr roleplay dialoge und sachen drumherum leider haben beide games das problem dass sie zum ende hin ziemlich abbauen
falls irgendjemand mal ein game spielen will also was production value und story und komplexität und grafik mit ballus geld 3 bei weitem nicht mithalten kann aber falls einer mal eine wirklich gute dungeons and treasures
fifth edition umsetzung sehen will in dem game dem kann ich das hier empfehlen
auf steam das ist so ziemlich so ziemlich die beste grafik ist halt
grausam ja aber das ist ziemlich die beste fifth edition umsetzung die ihr
als game finden werdet also da merkt man auch was in baldur's gate 3 eigentlich
alles fehlt an optionen die man im kampf so hat aber dafür baldur's gate 3
ganz andere stärken also es hängt ein bisschen davon ab was man was man gerne
mag ja also ich will ich würde sagen generell vom gameplay her und und vom
aufbau finde ich was auf der reich ist super game geworden für alle role
player die auch gerne abseits von kämpfen so ein bisschen dialoge haben
und auch viele unterschiedliche ausgangs
unternehmenswerte
unterschiedliche optionen haben wollen so nach dem motto wie man ein spiel
als baldur's gate 3 und wer mal wer dungeons and dragons pur spielen will
fifth edition da kann sich so laster angucken alternativ einfach alle drei
sachen spielen weil warum nicht ist nicht so als könnte man sich nicht
leisten so teuer sind die games nicht für das was man bekommt und spielzeit
wohlgemerkt alles klar leute hoffentlich hat's wo
da war
vorne auf die reihe bekommen morgen früh ist denn wo man müde wo man schlafen bett
geteilt wir sehen uns bis dann